''Bruit de tram''
*Musique*
Bonjour et bienvenue dans cette troisième vidéo au Japon, on est à Tokyo
Et plus précisément à Akihabara, souvenez-vous c'est le quartier geek où on a avait visité un sex-shop avec Cyprien
Bon, y'a trop de trous dans cette chose!
*Rires*
On va pas commençer par le sex-shop, mais on va aller dans une petite salle d'arcade
Y'en a une juste ici ça tombe bien !
Mais quel bon youtubeur, Oh la la la
Es-tu excité d'être dans cet endroit ?
Plutôt oui, plutôt!
Bon avec mon frère, on veux s'affronter sur Teken
Le jeu de notre enfance
*TA-TA-TA-TAAAAA*
J'ai pris Bob, il a pris Bryan
On s'en fout de ce que tu dis Florent
Ce qui compte c'est que tu perdes!
''Combat''
KO (Hors Combat)
C'est Lucas, c'est Lucas Hauchard
Oh non, il a esquivé latéralement!
Il mène 2/1 il remonte
Fils de p***! Fils de p***!
Il fait 0 Chop, Il contre 0 Chop et il gagne
C'est honteux ou pas?
OUAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!
Wah ça fait du bien!
*Rires*
YES!
C'était chaud!
On vient de sortir du bâtiment, on a joué pendant une heure
et le problème c'est que dans les salles d'arcades
les japonais on le droit de fumer à l'intérieur
Et du coup ça pue la clope
Quand tu sort de là tu pues de ouf!
*Snif*
Tu pues!
Les amis je suis extrêmement content
On vient de rentrer dans un magasins de figurines
Et je suis tombé sur le Iron Man Samouraï
Il est absolument incroyable, mon frère a craqué
Regardez-le il lui fait l'amour!
Mais c'est pas tout car j'ai aussi pris
Le Spider Man
Donc à Akihabara on peut trouver tout ce qui a un rapport avec la culture geek y compris des cartes!
Y en a un paquet
Putain y a des cartes DBZ...
Elles sont trop belles, elle brillent toutes j'ai l'impression que c'est des cartes légendaires!
Je sais pas si vous le saviez, mais il y a certaines cartes de certains jeux
Qui peuvent coûter jusqu'à 1000€ selon leur rareté, voir plus
C'est complètement dingue...
Les amis je suis à nouveau dans une salle d'arcade
Et je viens de tomber sur la figurine la plus perverse et la plus cool de tous les temps
Je vais donc investir pour la remporter, et la mettre dans mon décor
Bon, petit bilan de la situation
Au cas où vous ne le saviez pas, ces machines en fait sont réglées manuellement
Tous les jours à des heures différentes
Y a un bouton qui règle la force de la prise, de la pince ; un bouton qui règle la force d'appui etc... BREF
La machine sur laquelle on est tombé, j'ai pas eu de chance, elle était faite pour que tu perdes
C'est pour ça qu'il faut toujours regarder un mec jouer avant soi
Pour voir si la pince agrippe ou pas
Et ça change selon les jours et les heures et les machines, c'est terrible!
Et je me suis obstiné pour une fille au gros seins
Comme beaucoup de gens tous les jours en France... j'aurais jamais dû! Je regrette tellement!
C'est une défaite totale pour Lucas Hauchard aujourd'hui
Après, je vais pas vous mentir, je sais quoi faire pour me consoler...
C'est bon ça va mieux, je me sens dans mon élément
Florent : Je suis très très excité
J'pense fort à toi Cyprien
Florent : ça m'excite...
Thierry : Ah ouais d'accord, quand même...
Bon les amis, je suis sorti de ce magasin malsain
J'ai acheté un petit cadeau qu'on va offrir ce soir à quelqu'un
Je ne vous dis pas ce que c'est, je ne vous dis non plus le nom de la personne à qui je vais l'offrir
Ça va être très drôle et surtout très gênant
Là on va aller au plus gros magasin de figurines de l'endroit
Et on va essayer de voir si y a pas des trucs cool...
Saviez vous que Tom Cruz n'avait pas de zizi
Bon là ce qui se passe c'est hyper glauque ...
Tu peux acheter ici des corps nus de figurines
Et ensuite tu achètes les têtes de tes stars préférés
Bonjour je suis Jacky Chan mais en fin de carrière
Florent je crois que tu as une idée c'est ça ?
Jacky Chan ; Corps de femme
Personne ne veut voir ça Flo !
*TIN-TIN-TIIIIN*
Super glauque !
Attention j'ouvre le corps
J'crois qu'on est en train de créer la plus belle figurine du monde
OH PUTAIN ! Alors j'peux pas vous le montrer pour le moment faut que je censure
Flo : Faut un lacet ?
Oh mais mec regarde la texture
Florent : Mais nan!
Ah ouais, ça pue !
Ouais, nan, elle pue du cul !
*Snif*
Florent : Ouah !
Florent : Est-ce que c'est pas un peu ton rêve de faire ça?
Par contre, j'crois que...
Florent : Bah, qu'est-ce que tu nous fais ?
Florent : Nan mais on dirait que t'écartes les jambes
Mais nan mais nan... c'est juste qu'elle tient pas
Florent : En fait c'est limite pervers
Ouais c'est pervers en fait!
On fait comme les meufs en soirée, on remonte un peu le décolleté
Oh putain!
Ok le devant...
Et attention le derrière
Ah putain mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait à Jackie Chan
Attention l'élément final
*Musique épique pour cette situation WTF*
Franchement ça le fait
Florent : Alors maintenant j'aimerais faire un p'tit kiff
Oooooohhhh!!! *rire*
Florent : Digne des plus grands
Regardez le... on dirait qu'il est vrai
Non... non non! Ne le fais pas me regarder comme ça!
Ça me dérange!
Jackie, qu'est-ce qu'il t'es arrivé!
Tu as envie ? De me faire des câlins ?
Salut, c'est Jackie Chan! N'hésite pas à t'abonner!
Bon, il est maintenant temps de rejoindre deux copains youtubeurs...
...dont l'un qui va recevoir un beau cadeau
Florent : Allez peace!
Ouais, mais je regardais, j'ai eu peur.
Surpriiiiise!
Il est beau, il s'appelle Nozman, Hein.
Germain dans la vrai vie, attention!
Ici on à qui?
On à JD!
On vient de manger, c'était super bien.
J'ai un p'tit cadeau pour JD!
Ah! Tu voulais te mettre en place pour euh... que je fasse le cadeau.
Déja, quand c'est emballé là d'dans.
Quand c'est emballé là d'dans, tu sais que ça va pas.
Vas y, à toi
Pourquoi tu ris, y'à rien encore!
Moi j'ai vu quelque chose en vrai.
Je pense savoir c'que c'est en fait.
Attention
D'accord
Tu peux voir ici c'que c'est.
C'est une main qui va pouvoir me servir aaaaa...
a quelques plaisirs.
C'est une actrice pornographique japonaise.
Ils ont modélisé son corps et c'est une reproduction parfaite de son bras et de sa main.
Merci beaucoup!
On va l'ouvrir, je penses que c'est le parfait moment, on  est dans un restaurant.
C'est l'endroit idéal.
Ah! C'est glauque !
C'est quoi ce bras flex mon gars?
Tiens, on dirait le sort Harry Potter où çà de détruit le bras.
En faite, c'est le bras d'Harry Potter
Çà sens bizarre.
Ah! Mais me gifle pas avec ce bras mec!
Mais c'est quoi le délire. Il est... il est tout mou mec.
J'ai pas compris.
Mais pourquoi il est mou comme ça ?
J'pensais que c'était dur.
Mais c'est pas un gant les gars.
Mais c'est un bras à fracture ouverte en en faite.
C'est un fantasme ici la fracture ouverte?
Ah putain..
Merci beaucoup Lucas!
Ben j'ten pris!
C'est pour me faire pardonner de ta défaite sur le quiz YouTube.
Ah oui! Bah ouais. Super!
C'est beaucoup mieux.
Eh bien les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo.
Merci Germain, Allias Nozman.
Merci à toi! Çà fait plaisir. J'ai pas eu de cadeaux, mais c'est pas grave.
JD qui joue avec son... son nouveau jouet.
Ah j'aime beaucoup ouais.
Et n'oubliez pas, le pouce en l'air!
Aller! Au revoir!
Hola qué tal !
Aujourd'hui, on va aller à Harajuku c'est un endroit où il y a plein de boutiques cools, mais ça on s'en fout
Mais ce que je vais faire surtout c'est aller chez le coiffeur,
parce que là ça devient critique de malade!
Et je me suis dit ça peux être drôle d'aller dans un coiffeur japonais et de lui dire :
Écoute, fais moi ce que tu veux!
Aller c'est parti!
Bon, je suis à Harajuku devant un salon de coiffure très, très beau.
On va voir si il y a de la place.
Bon, le salon est plein, on est hyper déçus.
En plus, il y avait marqué des prix genre : Meilleur salon d'Europe même si le Japon c'est pas en Europe, c'est pas grave.
Je suis dans un salon.
Et ça va peut être passer.
Ça serait bien que ça se passe ici, le salon est cool.
Du coup, j'pense pas que j'me retrouverais avec les cheveux bleus.
Bonne nouvelle, il y a de la place et ils acceptent que je filme dans le salon.
C'est très, très cool et on va dire au revoir à ses cheveux euh... nul.
<<Du coup, j'pense pas que j'me retrouverais avec les cheveux bleus>>
Ca va être très très drôle.
Est-ce qu'on est en train de faire une vidéo de Youtuber Life Style?
Oui. Est-ce que que j'ai honte?
Oui
Tu peux avoir de l'eau pétillante dans tes cheveux mon gars.
Quel est le fuck!
Donc, si on fait le bilan, je suis en train de me laver les cheveux avec de la San Pellegrino.
Normalement, j'en achète à la boulangerie en bas du bureau, mais bon ok.
En France, j'avais jamais vu ça.
J'avais jamais vu de coiffeur tout court.
En fait, c'est trop con mais le fait d'être allongé bah t'as pas mal au cou.
Et d’ailleurs, j'avais lu un truc sur ça des barres.
Anecdote incroyable!
Y a des gens qui sont mort, chez le coiffeur, parce que justement leurs nuques appuyaient énormément sur le truc.
Et du coup, ça fait une bulle dans tes veines qui monte au cerveau et t'es mort.
C'est genre un cas sur des milliard, mais tu peux crever chez le coiffeur à cause de ça!
Hein!
Qu'est-ce qui ce passe là?
Attend mais le osen j'ai dis que je voulais plus
Nickel... Je passe un bon moment
Bon on va maintenant passer à la couleur
Je sais pas quelle couleur elle va faire, on va le découvrir
Ça va être très amusant
*Pa-Pa-Pa-Paaaa*
Oui, ces cheveux sont très violet
"atrêve" le rêve devient réalité
Eh bien mon rêve est devenu réalité
Voila ma nouvelle coupe
C'est elle qui a tout décidé, j'avais ce délire, je voulais absolument rentrer un salon de coiffure au Japon et dire : Ecoutez moi bien, vous faite ce que vous voulez
J'crois que mon souhait à été exaucé
Ça change énormément
C'est très amusant
C'est exactement ce que je voulais
Et au pire si ça me plait pas, je rase tout à blanc
Je m'en bat les cou**** frère
Et là, j'ai hâte d'un truc, c'est de voir voir la réaction de mon père et de mon père
Aller, on va les retrouver
Thierry : Ouuuuuuuuh...
Florent : Alors là...
Florent : On dirait...
*Rire*
Florent : Un vieux militaire américain
Florent : Qui s'est pris une décharge d'encre violette dans le...
*Rires*
Florent : Eh il est beau le violet hein ?
Il est beau, c'est un beau violet
Florent : Franchement c'est un beau violet
Thierry : Ah ouais c'est un super violet
Florent : C'est censé être comment la coupe ?
Normalement c'était levé à gauche, à balle la comme ça là
Florent : Bah ça va mec, elle t'a fait ça bien
Eh ben ouais !
Florent : T'es content toi ?
Ouais j'suis content, je m'en fout moi
puis au moins ça change ça fait du bien
Florent : La couleur elle est chouette
Thierry : La couleur est jolie
Et bien on termine sur ces mots gentils des Hauchard c'est rare mais ça fait plaisir ils sont mignons
Florent : Tu est moche quand même
Voilà!
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine probablement à Paris cette fois car oui le séjour touche à sa fin...
Aller à bientôt! Au revoir!